Hi everyone, and welcome to Biology Professor.
Today, we're talking about photosynthesis
and cell respiration.
Basically, we're going to look at how those
two are connected and what they have in common.
Now, they're actually a lot more connected
than most people think.
They're part of a large cycle that starts
with energy that comes from the sun.
The sun provides light energy that is absorbed
by chloroplasts.
This is where photosynthesis happens.
Photosynthesis yields two types of products.
First, organic molecules.
Most common one you will hear about is glucose,
so a type of sugar.
The other major product yielded by photosynthesis
is oxygen or O2.
Organic molecules, like glucose, and oxygen
are then used by mitochondria in cellular
respiration.
This is where the mitochondria have enzymes
present that, through several complicated
steps, break down organic molecules using
oxygen as a final electron acceptor to generate
something very, very important - ATP.
ATP is basically the energy currency of the
cell.
It's like a dollar bill.
Everywhere in the cell takes it.
And this is where the energy is stored that
the cell can later use for a variety of cellular
processes.
Now, where does this cycle part come in.
In mitochondria, with cell respiration, once
they have used the organic molecules and the
oxygen, there are two different products that
are formed.
These are carbon dioxide and water.
Carbon dioxide and water are the two reactants
that chloroplasts need to carry out photosynthesis,
so that is how this is one big cycle.
Now, let's look at what these processes, photosynthesis
and cell respiration, what do they have in
common?
Well, they both use electron transport chains.
Electron transport chains are these series
of enzymes that are part of biological membranes
that pass electrons from place to place within
that chain, and in so doing, they harvest
energy from those electrons and create something
called a proton gradient.
The proton gradient is then used in both photosynthesis
and cell respiration by ATP synthase.
And this is another common misconception.
People think that ATP is only involved in
cell respiration, and it's true that cell
respiration is where the cell gets the ATP
that it needs for all of its different functions,
but photosynthesis has ATP synthase as well.
In photosynthesis, ATP synthase is used to
generate ATP in an early step of photosynthesis
that is then used up in a later step of photosynthesis
where the organic molecules are being made,
so ATP is a part of both of these things.
Also, both photosynthesis and cell respiration
in plants, algae, and photosynthetic bacteria.
People are tempted to say that autotrophs
like plants use photosynthesis and heterotrophs
like animals use cell respiration.
That's true, but actually, plants use BOTH,
and algae and photosynthetic bacteria, they
use both.
They use the photosynthesis to generate the
organic molecules and the oxygen and they
use the mitochondria that they have for cell
respiration to get the ATP that they need
for all of their various functions.
Now, I also want to mention as a side note
that photosynthetic bacteria - you might be
saying "well, how can they have photosynthesis,
when they don't have chloroplasts?"
That's true.
Bacteria are prokaryotic cells, so they lack
organelles.
So they don't have chloroplasts, they don't
have mitochondria.
Instead, the enzymes that are used in photosynthesis
and cell respiration, they have as part of
their plasma membrane, instead of being specifically
in the cells in these compartmentalized places.
Now, another thing that these two processes
have in common is that they use biological
membranes for increased surface area.
What does this mean?
Well, cells are very small places and they
have a lot going on inside of them.
You see that chloroplasts have this double
membrane system and then on the inside, they've
got more membranes.
The membranes here are in black.
And the mitochondrion also is a double membrane.
You've got the outer membrane and then you've
got this inner membrane that has lots and
lots of folds.
These folds are called cristae.
In chloroplasts, all of these individual little
ovals are called thylakoids.
And the thylakoids, when stacked together
in a column like this, form what's called
a granum.
So regardless of the terminology, in both
cases, you have a lot of biological membrane
that is folded up into a very little space
and it's these biological membranes - the
thylakoid membranes and the cristae membranes
- that hold those electron transport chains
where a big portion of photosynthesis and
cell respiration is happening.
So by having all of these folds or all of
these stacks of thylakoids, this provides
a lot of increased surface area so that photosynthesis
and cell respiration can happen at a very
high rate.
There's a lot of it going on at once because
it has all of this surface area to work with
even though it's in a small compartment.
And finally, another place that photosynthesis
and cell respiration are linked is in the
endosymbiotic theory.
This theory deals with the evolution of eukaryotes.
So, eukaryotes (as different from prokaryotes),
eukaryotes are these cells that have a lot
of membrane-bound organelles, so organelles
like chloroplasts, like mitochondria, but
also other organelles as well, lysosomes,
endoplasmic reticulum, the golgi apparatus,
the nucleus, all of these are specific to
eukaryotes.
The endosymbiotic theory says that mitochondria
and chloroplasts are special though, that
they were formed when an early ancestor of
eukaryotic cells engulfed a photosynthetic
prokaryotes that then became a chloroplast
and a non-photosynthetic eukaryote that then
became a mitochondrion, and that these two
organelles come from this ancient symbiosis
that was formed when prokaryotes were engulfed
by an early eukaryote.
So that is one other thing that photosynthesis
and cell respiration have in common.
That is it for today.
I hope you enjoyed it and thanks for watching!